so Donald Trump and his continued efforts
to hang out with North Korean dictator Kim
Jong [inaudible].
Ooh Man. But accomplished nothing of substance
has now gone to the demilitarized. So zone
on the North Korean border with South Korea
and actually stepped into North Korea something
a sitting American president has never done
an immediately. The Trumpists are arguing
that this is a great thing merely because
it hasn't happened before. Now later I'll
get to the way in which right wing media covered
Barack Obama's dealings with North Korea.
And you'll notice that there's a bit of a
hypocrisy, a bit of a double standard there.
Um, but this is a weird thing that lots of
people seem to not understand. Just because
Donald Trump is the first to do something
doesn't mean that that's a good thing. Trump's
the first president I recall who visibly mocked
a reporters handicap while running for president
in 2016. That doesn't mean Trump's a great
guy for doing it because nobody did that before.
And I think you can come up with many other
policy examples as well. So let's check out
some video of what Donald Trump said. For
some reason the, the uh, the pool audio was
off for just a few seconds too long from the
previous live translation of Korean that was
going on. So the first few seconds of Donald
Trump's statement or our cutoff, but we'll
pick it up on the audio comes back,
we expect it. You were in Japan for the g
20. We came over and I said, Hey, I'm over
here. I want to call it chairman Tim. And
we got to meet and stepping across that line
was a great on a lot of progress has been
made, a lot of friendships have been made
and this has been in particular a great friendship.
So I just want to thank you. That was very
quick to notice and I want to thank you.
Then there's a bit more from Donald Trump
right after the translation of that first
piece took place.
So we're going to get in touch. We're going
to talk for a little while about typical things
and a lot of really positive things are happening.
I bled you be here to say this, but tremendous
positivity, really great things are happening
and in a lot of places. But we met and we
liked each other from day one and that was
very important. The
the way that Donald Trump looks at Kim Jong-un
as the translation is happening, to gauge
whether Kim Jong Un likes what Trump said
is so reminiscent of like the fifth grader
who wants the middle school kids to like him
and is constantly monitoring the reactions
on their faces as as they talk. Trump also
reportedly has invited Kim Jong Un to come
to the White House, which would be very, very
interesting to say the least. So I think the
analysis here is maybe simpler than some might
think it is a good thing to try to have good
relationships with other countries for the
betterment of humanity. Okay. Avoiding conflict
and violence. That's good. Now some are being
critical of Donald Trump's actions because
they say, oh, Trump is legitimizing Kim Jong
loon. Even though Kim Jong Un is a violent
dictator. I don't think this is the right
critique. Number one, the u s has a long history
of legitimizing violent dictators.
That's not new. Number two, yes, Kim Jong
Un has been and will continue to use these
meetings with Trump and these invites from
Trump to um, uh, propagandize internally within
North Korea and propagandize the North Korean
people. But who cares? He's doing that anyway.
And that's not really at issue here outside
of North Korea. Trump doing this does not
legitimize Kim Jong UN in any materially relevant
way. So I don't think that's the right critique.
The problem is that Trump doesn't realize
he's getting played. Okay. Before the first
meeting with Kim Jong, when Trump bragged
about how he was able to secure a meeting
with, with a, a North Korean leader, um, any
president could have met with any North Korean
dictator. It has been the American presidents
who didn't want to do it without some preconditions
because it would likely be pointless. And
case in point, none of the North Korean dictators,
including Kim Jong and so far in his dealings
with Trump, have stuck to these tired, vague
promises that they've been making for decades.
And Trump doesn't realize that he's getting
played. That's the real critique. And because
Donald Trump accomplishes nothing in these
meetings, remember missile testing has continued,
the propaganda has continued, the threats
have continued. This suggests that the United
States is okay with treating regimes that
oppress and pillage their own populations
in the same way that we treat western liberal
democracies. It's an incredible hypocrisy,
but it's also not surprising because we know
that Donald Trump has been very taken with
the likes of Putin and do Duterte. Tay and
I forgot the rest of the list, and Kim Jong
UN is on that list and he's been increasingly
alienating France and Germany and the United
Kingdom and Canada. So that's the real critique.
Legitimizing Kim Jong Un. It's kind of a weak
critique and we legitimized Kim Jong-un in
many different ways all the time. We shouldn't
understate the value of this. Also as a stunt
to take attention away from Trump's absolutely
disastrous failed diplomacy with Iran and
the almost war that Donald Trump started because
when Fox News and whoever else on the Trumpist
Wright starts praising Donald Trump for doing
this, for stepping into North Korea and continuing
to praise gushing Lee Kim Jong [inaudible].
Uh, it does frame Trump as a successful diplomat,
which he is not remember. And again, he's
accomplished nothing practical or tangible
with North Korea. And it takes attention away
from the almost true disaster that was Trump's
authorized strike against Iran. And then at
the last second calling it back, supposedly
after being told by the military what the
civilian casualties would be, even though
it is extraordinarily difficult to believe
that the military would not have briefed Trump
on that earlier
on
in
the game.